it's halloween night in chicago the
stores along main avenue are leaving out
bowls of candy for the evening's
trick-or-treaters streets are closed off
for the big parade downtown and young
children are running home from school to
jump into their favorite costumes it's a
night of harmless spooky fun for most
but not everyone a police cruiser pulled
up outside of an apartment building on
kenmore avenue overlooking the graceland
cemetery a pair of seasoned officers
climbed out and made their way up to the
13th floor there had been multiple
reports of terrified screaming echoing
through the building throughout the
night with someone getting a little too
into the halloween spirit and watching a
horror movie at ear splitting volume or
was this something altogether more
sinister the police officers approached
the door of apartment 1330b and wrapped
on the hardwood ma'am
is everything okay in there no reply
they repeated themselves a little louder
this time they could hear movement from
within but still no answer came that was
enough probable cause for them to kick
in the front door the officers swept the
apartment going from room to room hands
hovering over their holsters kitchen
nothing bedroom nothing but the living
room was a whole different horror story
to their utter disbelief a human
skeleton was standing in front of them
holding a swath of flayed human skin
still dripping with fresh blood the
skeleton was forcing one of its legs
into the bloody sack as though it was
slipping on a halloween costume on the
floor nearby a pile of human bones sat
atop mangled flesh the officers gasped
at the site and the skeleton turned to
face them without hesitation it dropped
the flayed skin and lunged wrapping its
icy fingers around their throats the
rest was a cacophony of screams and
gunshots which soon gurgled and choked
into a terrible silence an hour later a
team of forensic specialists cordoned
off the area while another officer
photographed the crime scene a pair of
detectives paced around the apartment
trying to piece together what happened a
pair of armed well-trained officers
strangled with such force that their
necks snapped and across from them was a
pile of bloody bones meat and human skin
before the detectives had time to draw
any conclusions a group of black suited
fbi agents arrived and ordered the local
cops to vacate the area they were taking
over the investigation now don't worry
these weren't agents from the unusual
incidence unit here to bungle this case
further they were scp foundation field
agents undercover and actively searching
for a certain ornary bag of bones
scp-3114 a skeleton that the adjectives
spooky and scary don't even begin to
cover but first a question
wouldn't it be chilly to have no skin on
it's an old nursery rhyme that you might
have heard during your childhood and if
you ask our professional opinion here at
scp explained we'd say yes it would be
and
scp-3114 can confirm this from
first-hand experience that's why if ever
you run into it it may leave the
encounter wearing your skin
that's right
scp-3114 is a skeleton so desperate to
be just like us it's willing to skin any
human it meets and wear our bloody pelts
like a halloween costume this probably
leaves you with a very understandable
question so
what's his whole deal and thankfully we
have at least some of the answers to
that after conducting a series of
cognitive tests on the anomaly
foundation researchers concluded that
scp-3114 responds primarily to visual
stimuli with its other senses ranging
from muted to non-existent if something
even vaguely humanoid enters its line of
sight 3114 will enter its rage state
making a beeline for the victim and
strangling them to death researchers
believe 3114 chooses strangulation as
its favor murder method because it
leaves the skin intact aside from a few
minor bruises and abrasions and once the
victim is dead it will begin
meticulously cutting them open and
removing their bones again trying its
best to do as little damage to the skin
as possible
scp-3114 will then attempt to wear the
skin as its own eventually discarding it
after wear and tear sets in in one
interaction subject d 1724 an adult male
entered scp-3114
containment chamber
scp-3114 attacked him reacting with an
increased level of aggression when the
man tried to fight back
scp-3114 damaged the body of
d-1724 to the point that halfway through
removing his bones it decided that even
the skin was beyond salvaging it
discarded the body in the corner of its
enclosure placing sticks and boxes over
it in what researchers believed to be a
form of pseudo-burial tests on
scp-3114's physical makeup indicate that
it is stronger and more resilient than a
normal human skeleton owing to it being
made from a far denser material than
non-anomalous human bones during tests
researchers attacked the bones with
sledgehammers power tools and other
means of exterior impact concluding that
it took up to three times more force to
break one of the anomalies bones than
those of a normal person
scp-3114 also has regenerative healing
properties being able to mend broken
bones at shocking speeds making the
creature effectively immortal even
though
scp-3114 has no musculature or
connective tissue of any kind its
skeleton is still somehow to support
itself and move independently when a
bone is removed or pulled away from its
place it will quickly return to its
original position once a force is no
longer acting on it it also has far
greater speed and strength than your
average non-anomalous human despite its
lack of muscles
scp-3114 also seems to have some
semblance of intelligence as an
extension of its drive to appear more
human it even has periods of dormancy
where it mimics human sleep researchers
have placed multiple items in
scp-3114's enclosure to observe how it
reacts these items have included sticks
boxes tires and building blocks a few
experiments even involved placing live
subjects into its enclosure often with
predictably violent results due to the
danger of being in proximity of scp-3114
foundation researchers use projections
of humans to lure it into a smaller
secondary containment cell adjacent to
its primary enclosure foundation staff
are barred from entry until
scp-3114 has been locked in this
secondary cell only then can items be
added or removed from its habitat mess
this up and you're all but guaranteed a
closed casket funeral something this
strong and aggressive can create
considerable containment challenges for
the foundation so they started exploring
a new question what can pacify this
walking skeleton's homicidal wrath two
things as it turns out the first is
finding a skin that fits just right
researchers placed a freshly deceased
male cadaver into
scp-3114's enclosure naturally
scp-3114 began to systematically remove
the bones of the cadaver one by one then
place the skin of the corpse over its
own skeletal frame
scp-3114 seemed happy with its new skin
observing itself in a mirror scp-3114
studied the reflection from different
angles attempting to smile with its
sagging face and mimicking hand gestures
one might see in common social
situations intrigued by this development
researchers sent d-4843 into the chamber
to interact directly with scp-3114
upon coming face-to-face with
scp-3114 wearing decaying human skin the
human subject became terrified and
attempted to leave the enclosure
scp-3114 persisted in trying to interact
with the d-class attempting a handshake
and even caressing
d-4843's face its stolen skin sculpted
into an unflinching smile the d-class
was not charmed by this instead he wet
himself and was allowed to leave the
enclosure to change his underwear
scp-3114 seemed confused by the
subject's fear and subsequent departure
waiting by the door for him to come back
he then grew frustrated and looked at
itself in the mirror again this time
reacting angrily and violently tearing
off its skin perhaps made self-conscious
by the d-class's reaction to its new
face from that encounter researchers
concluded that
scp-3114 would not immediately attack if
it was wearing a skin that it deemed
suitable the second thing that calms
this bag of bones is the companionship
of man's best friend that's right
scp-3114
has a proclivity towards dogs this was
discovered in the series of experiments
where the foundation cross-tested the
anomaly with a variety of animal
specimens the first of these animals was
a gorilla scp-3114
appeared to exhibit some hesitation at
first indicating a level of recognition
between humans and our not so distant
evolutionary cousins but unfortunately
the confrontation ended violently when
the gorilla became agitated and tried to
exert its dominance over scp-3114
this led to a physical altercation where
the gorilla was overpowered and killed
though not without breaking one of
scp-3114's ribs first thankfully the
second attempt at animal interaction
this time with a border collie went much
smoother
scp-3114 took care to be gentle when
playing with and petting the dog and
even when the dog attempted to bite one
of its leg bones scp-3114
did not react in an exponentially
violent manner the pair spent the better
part of two hours playing together
playing fetch and seeming to enjoy each
other's company it's comforting to know
that there are at least some things
capable of temporarily taming this stack
of murderous calcium but what happens
when it breaches containment this brings
us back to our halloween crime scene an
embedded field agent in the fbi
introduced himself as special agent
thomas seaward he spoke to the local
detectives on the scene showing them a
badge they didn't recognize and asking
them to come downstairs to a mobile
office outside the building where they
would be debriefed members of mobile
task force gamma 5 also known as the red
herrings were waiting in this unit to
administer amnestics to any members of
local law enforcement who knew about the
case they would later also canvas the
building for other witnesses and make
arrangements to ensure that the body cam
footage of the two fallen officers would
be destroyed it was also unclear exactly
how scp-3114
escaped containment but recapturing the
subject for the safety of the local
population remained of paramount
importance with this goal in mind agent
sieward mobilized mtf pi one also known
as the city slickers a mobile task force
that specializes in the investigation
containment and subsequent cleanup of
anomalies in densely populated urban
environments under the guise of the fbi
the pai-1 members spread across the
streets of chicago in black vehicles
monitoring police scanners for reports
or sightings of walking skeletons
attacking the civilian population
meanwhile several blocks away scp-3114
found itself walking past a row of
clothing stores it stopped at the site
of a mannequin modeling sportswear and a
window display instead of charging at
the humanoid figure with lethal intent
scp-3114 calmly walked into the store
and approached the mannequin he began to
study the figure taking off its clothes
and trying them on piece by piece when
it was fully clothed it assumed the
mannequin's pose but then it began to
observe itself in a nearby mirror with
wrapped fascination a store clerk
emerged from the back room noticing that
someone was trying on clothes outside of
the changing room he walked over to
offer assistance but was stopped in his
tracks at the site of this strange new
customer and the turn of his bleached
white skull not long after that the
anomaly left the store wearing the
clerk's skin as it emerged onto the
streets unnoticed amidst the throng of
trick-or-treaters
scp-3114 took in its surroundings what a
strange new world it found itself in
then it spotted a nearby group of
trick-or-treaters wearing various
costumes most notably a plastic skull
mask
scp-31
had found its people excited by the
prospect of another walking skeleton
scp-3114 decided to follow the group as
they sauntered over to a larger crowd
gathering on the main avenue for the
annual halloween parade among the many
participants dressed as werewolves and
vampires and other classic halloween
creatures
scp-3114 noticed a group of creators
dressed as skeletons dancing and walking
together people were cheering them on
taking photos and smiling at the
spectacle perhaps it wasn't so bad to be
a bone man after all and everyone else
at the parade had their eyes on scp-3114
they didn't see it as a violent
anomalous skeleton wearing skins stolen
from an innocent store clerk they saw it
as one of the most brilliantly realistic
costumes the parade had ever seen people
stared and waved and smiled in awe and
scp-3114 was loving every bit of
attention soon enough
scp-3114 was leading the parade waving
gleefully at the crowds of impressed
trick-or-treaters it walked with the
others for several blocks occasionally
picking up fallen candy to throw at the
crowd wow great costume that looks super
real mister call the nearby
eight-year-old marveling up at scp-3114
do you want to come trick-or-treating
with us emotion to a group of three
costume friends they were all dressed as
members of the avengers
scp-3114 turned its bony head draped in
its stolen skin and followed the eager
kids as they began walking from house to
house asking for halloween treats
watching the children stick out their
bags and plastic pumpkins asking for
candy
scp-3114 began mimicking the behavior it
even picked up and started to carry its
own plastic pumpkin meanwhile across
town agent thomas seward was notified
about a pile of bloody bones found
behind the counter in an upmarket
clothing store only one creature in town
tonight could be behind that
scp-3114 seward made a call to all
available gamma-5 members requesting a
cleanup on-site and comprehensive and
monastic treatment for all witnesses at
the crime scene seward and his team hit
the bricks searching the surrounding
area he noticed the large crowds leaving
the parade with some adolescents
marveling at the amazing costume the
zombie looking guy was wearing and at
that moment it all came together for
agent seward what better place for a
monster wearing human skin to hide than
in plain sight on halloween he mused to
himself while unclipping his radio from
his jacket seward ordered all available
agents to converge on the main avenue
and search any trick-or-treaters wearing
any costume that looked like rotting
human skin they were on the clock if
they didn't get to
scp-3114 before its current skin suit
degraded fully it would claim another
life tonight meanwhile
scp-3114 itself continued its night out
in public trick-or-treating with a group
of children who were blissfully unaware
of how much danger they were in as they
went home to home the creature's costume
started to take on a pallid green
complexion as the rot set in it gave off
the most repulsive smell at some point
flies even began to gather around it to
any ignorant passerby it was still the
most horrifying and brilliant costume
they'd ever seen and whoever was wearing
it must have been so committed to the
character because they never said a word
as the night wore on the children each
got calls from their mothers telling
them it was time to come home after all
the obligatory grumbles they gave in and
did so wishing their strange silent
friend in the horrifying zombie costume
a happy halloween this left scp-3114
adrift wandering around not sure exactly
what to do with itself perhaps it was
time to find a new skin maybe then
people would want to hang out with it
again the anomaly was distracted from
its dangerous thoughts by a dog barking
on a nearby lawn
scp-3114 was delighted to find another
four-legged friend out here in the wild
and approach to pet the tiny creature as
it wagged its little tail how nice it
felt to finally have a familiar comfort
again that's when i noticed one more
little boy wandering the lonely streets
a new friend perhaps
scp-3114 would follow him and see just a
few blocks down scp agents scoured the
streets with flashlights asking anyone
they could if they'd seen someone
wearing an eerily realistic costume with
little in the way of success
agent seward was in the middle of
questioning a man who had participated
in the parade earlier that night when he
got a phone call from one of his
subordinates listening to police
scanners agents had intercepted a call
coming from a terrified mother who
claimed that a grown man in a strange
costume had followed her little boy home
the agents immediately made their way to
the address making sure local police
were notified not to respond to the call
upon arrival they found that scp-314
had broken into the family's living room
and was petting the family's dog the
skin suit had almost fully degraded now
hanging off the monster's body like
rotten bologna they didn't have much
time agent seward had his men surround
the building as a containment vehicle
backed up towards the home they couldn't
engage
scp-3114 directly without the risk of a
fatality that's why they'd fitted the
inside of the vehicle with a projector
just like the one inside scp-3114
sell to lure it back into the trap soon
enough just as seward and all the others
had predicted
scp-3114 began to angrily tear off the
rotten skin of the unfortunate store
clerk its bones shown in the moonlight
once more stained with blood the next
person that saw would be dead so it was
extremely lucky that the next person it
saw was the hologram of a male d-class
standing deep in the back of the
containment vehicle's portable cell
scp-3114 sped towards the hologram
grasping claws outstretched so intent on
getting its new skin that it didn't even
notice the bulkhead closing behind it
agent seward breathed a sigh of relief
as the vehicle drove off to the nearest
containment site but for him and the
rest of his men the night had just begun
they still had a hell of a mess to clean
up and all this just so that murderous
skeleton could have a happy halloween
now go check out
scp-060 infernal occult skeleton and
scp-1123 atrocity skull for more
nightmarish anomalous bones